how's it going guys Matt here with code
Tech tutorials bringing you a little
video now the video I wanted to bring
out this Wednesday wasn't quite ready
and still isn't I'll bring it out when I
can but turns out some of this coding
stuff is hard so I'm doing sort of a
filler episode just to get something for
you guys this week especially for you
guys that support me and really want to
see stuff and let me know through uh
signing up for my stuff like the patreon
and Etc I gotta do something for you
guys because I really appreciate you so
I'm gonna put together this little video
here about Nvidia physics and trying to
get a player moving correctly with it
because it has been mind-numbingly more
difficult than I would have expected but
I'm going to show you all the tricks
I've learned so far and hopefully you'll
get something out of this especially if
you like doing physics stuff maybe some
ideas for how to do movement in the
future a little bit of context this is
basically an early iteration potentially
throwaway code that will be refactored
for a game I'm working on that uh
hopefully will come out at the end of
the year that's the plan anyway so let
me just uh show you a few things all
right this is just some movement code
but kind of want to like just show you
first I'm going to hit play on this and
we're going to launch it to a little
Demo World here and this is just a
Sandbox level but I can look around with
the mouse I'm in a first person view
I've got some sticks over there
following just as a physics test just
some basic ground and I've got some
borders just temporary borders just to
have something Shadows not configured
right but I don't care right now I'll
mess with that later so I've got some
wazda movement here and you can see you
know you can't really tell that I'm
pressing buttons sure but you can see
that I'm just you know hitting them all
and doing little circles like you would
in a first person game but this is
physics based movement here essentially
the player is a capsule I can look
around and when I press forward it
starts giving me some push
foreign
notice how when I do a quick turnaround
momentum still carries me kind of like
we're driving a vehicle or something
and I ramp off those sticks
exceptionally hard but that's kind of
the point we wanted some physics-based
movement but also I don't want it to
feel too clunky I've tried to turn too
fast when you're moving too fast yeah
you can't exactly do it depending on
your foot traction so I'm trying to
emulate that a little bit now keep in
mind again this isn't final this is just
temporary but as you can see these nice
kind of gradual turning curves it makes
when I turn is kind of cool
you can maybe 360 no scope you know you
can face any direction but as you press
forward it tries to correct to that
direction however there is a trick to
this whenever I stop moving
rather than keeping on gliding it
immediately stops when we stop pressing
the movement Keys we stop so there's
probably some tricks to turn around
super quick like rather than having to
Glide a turn you stop for a second spin
so you know people that play this for a
long time if I kept the same movement
system would just do that if they needed
to turn they'd stop spin
or you could try it this way where you
just spin the cam and let it keep going
and kind of get that U Parabola feel and
also get jump in the mix
you can jump too and it you know pushes
you up the Jump's not quite right yet
but if you're moving and you jump it's
really hard to tell so that's kind of a
weird thing I've been trying to figure
out like I don't know what I need to do
to correct that so I'm just standing
there kind of jumps okay
all right so what what I'll set up here
you might ask let's take it from the top
we're working with physics 4.1 and the
reason we're working with physics 4.1 is
because that is what my package manager
supports right now and that is the one
that is Battle tested and actually used
in development I know physics 5 is out
and they recommend using it but until my
package manager has like confirmed it
and has it stable there I'm not gonna do
that so we're gonna stick with 4.1.2 so
that's the first thing if you're
comparing with some other different
version of physics your results May Vary
I have no idea so physics is initialized
NVIDIA physics has a couple different
ways they do this now if you Google
search this and try to figure out how
the best way to implement character
movement they basically tell you you
want a player controller class PX player
controller and if you just do a Google
search for it with this version you'll
find some documentation on the character
controller but the whole problem here
with these character controllers I mean
you know I read through all this I
implemented it it took all the time to
get all this stuff set up and then I
found out that this is not what you
expect and half the stuff they have here
doesn't even work because I don't know
welcome to coding documentation hey you
new to coding the documentation is never
right get used to it getting all this
stuff set up finding out that half of it
isn't even in the API and it's just like
it was a real thing big problem with
this is it doesn't really interact with
physics entirely and I wanted a player
that did this is basically made for
cameras that can go through stuff and
that clip through walls and clip through
all the physics that's what like these
are for you want a camera that follows
people around and doesn't care about
Collision then this is what you want but
if you want like an actual thing in the
world that interacts with physics can't
really use this at least as far as I
could tell what you actually want is
just a standard Dynamic physics collider
if the player controller is not what I
want for my player controller we want to
move the player with physics so we have
an initialization function let me see
yeah here it is and essentially what
we're going to do is well I'm calling it
player controller but if you go look at
what this is uh my player controller
is a rigid Dynamic all right I've
typedef a rigid Dynamic to just a
controller and this player namespace so
I have a player controller and it's a
rigid dynamic because that's essentially
what we're using to push around our
character it's all it's going to be
physics based movement pushing around
that's going to make the game a lot
cooler yeah just a rigid Dynamic here so
create a capsule this function is from
their boilerplate code I modified it a
little bit to take a material so we can
give it static friction Dynamic friction
or restitution of a set amount because
you probably don't want all your players
to Glide and behave the same
these are tricky to figure out the right
numbers but I feel like these were
pretty good at 0.5 on the static
friction of 0.8 on the dynamic and zero
on restitution uh
I wouldn't necessarily recommend those
you got to play around with these
numbers a lot if you don't know what all
those terms mean for physics highly
recommend Googling them yeah I'm going
to butcher it if I try to tell you but I
would recommend looking up static
friction Dynamic friction and
restitution with physics and just
observe those definitions because that's
how you need to know to set these so and
then I just put the player where we want
to make a rotation it's a px Squat and
make a transform this is based on our
player location and our rotation so
we're just kind of setting it in an
initial place there and then then we set
our controller with these rotation and
transforms this set Global pose and now
here's the important settings if you
don't want your capsule to tip over you
have to set Dynamic rigid Dynamic lock
Flags so I set one on Z and x and that's
why our capsule never Falls over is
because it literally can't lean those
directions we've got locked Flags
so if you ever wanted your capsule to
lean you would have to unlock it
temporarily lean it and then lean back
and lock it again because normally when
I'm doing all this moving around on this
game it would like it would like push it
around and it would roll and Tumble and
not stay straight up but since it's
locked then it stays straight up and we
can get a simulated effect of a standing
human for example or you know this could
just probably could be translated to be
a car or a bike or something you know
maybe this is even more suited to that
but I was trying to make a guy running
type scenario all right so we got those
locked Max linear
velocity
this determines the maximum speed that
this entity can go and I've got a
default walk speed defined you don't see
it here but I think it's currently like
100 and some or something so that's what
makes sure we don't Zoom too fast and we
get set to a max speed set player Mass
this is basically how heavy that object
is now Mass combines with the size so
the size of this capsule along with its
mass will determine how much of course
there's calculations with these
frictions as well so there's a lot of
things involved here basically a lot of
it will get dampened out due to its mass
and its size and these frictions so you
really got to play around with these
numbers to get it right add force is
typically what we use when we want to
move and because we have these locks and
these Max velocities adding forces can
only do so much and we're doing them as
a single impulse at a time so we can
keep adding forces until we hit these
Max speeds if we want and then you know
we're kind of at our max speed and it
solves gravy but right away here even in
the initialization I add a force
negative 1 on the Y that's down in our
case so we add a force down and I'm just
multiplying it by the scale just to make
sure it's it's big enough and this is
basically to make our character fall
into place so they're not sitting there
floating in the air potentially
depending on what land they're spawning
above so right on a net we just give
them a give them a little shove down and
that's something that we're going to
come back to quite a bit in this is the
shove down effect now why is this so
important well because you know the
Wiley Coyote cartoon where the coyote
would run off a cliff and he wouldn't
actually start falling until he stopped
and then looked down and realize there
was no land but you know realistically
he would start falling right away but
you know we got to avoid that
all right so that's the init let's look
at these systems so these happen more
when the game's actually running we got
a check cursor look this just determines
your Mouse stuff we're not going to
worry about that code too much but
basically there's a quick version of it
if you want to see it you gotta check
move Keys now this sets our movement
struct and as you can see we got all
these player movement dot forward dot
backwards there's a whole struct and it
gets updated anytime you press one of
the movement Keys basically every single
frame after these are processed they are
set back to false that's the way I
decided to design it you could also go
like it well else player movement false
Etc and that way you could just keep it
on until they are not pressing it
I chose not to go with this method
because I had a different idea in mind
so after process is your latest move
it's going to reset it somewhere else so
that's just done elsewhere is the point
now here's the run
this is a bit janky I need to do some
better here whenever you press left
shift it's going to set your max linear
velocity this is your maximum speed to a
new variable called max player speed
[Laughter]
all right so here's the reset movement
this is like a helper function this just
sets all that stuff to false
call at the end of applying forces we
got process events this is separate from
the physics it might eventually be part
of the physics but right now this is for
like picking up items and taking damage
and stuff
apply move forces so this gets called
once per frame
and this is what basically pushes the
character around so there are maybe some
oversights here as in maybe I should be
passing in Delta time actually now that
I think about I'm not sure why I'm not
but it's no matter uh we're going to
talk about it anyway because basically
I'm just applying direct forces and
they're based on the player Mass scale
so if we ever want to just adjust the
player Mass scale it's going to adjust
these forces as well which could be
quite relevant so we're kind of looking
for magic numbers in some of these slots
um but okay let's talk about this this
is the big one this is the the big daddy
of moving everything around we take in a
camera reference now why do we do this
because we want the forward direction we
want to know where the camera is looking
this is specifically the player cam so
maybe maybe I should even say that this
is the player's look camera so wherever
they're looking that's what direction we
want to apply our new forces
I don't know why I don't have Delta time
in here to be honest so I'm gonna I'll
sort that out on a later update like I
said this is all throw away kind of
getting started code for now just so I
can have a system a movement system that
kind of works and it kind of works get
around the world with objects and stuff
we have some static variables why static
you might ask the short answer is we
don't want to re-instantiate these every
time a call by moves so forces we just
want them to stay here and do what they
do these could be refactored out so we
got to move first this is basically to
check if we were forced uh Left Right
forward back if you were if you press
one of the Wasa Keys you are doing a
move force and that's uh what this is so
we'll get to that we want to know if the
move was forced because if not we have
kind of a different flow we go into
later all right we also have a timer
called the anti-glide timer this is for
when you stop moving basically there's a
little small amount of time that goes by
before it just freezes you in place so
that you don't just keep gliding forever
stop moving you should be able to plant
your feet in place let's see I'm holding
shift and running if I just keep it held
down and move I got to kind of make
these Parabola type shapes unless I
bounce off a wall bouncy
but if I just let go of everything it
stops me and that's what the anti-glide
timer does is it stops you in place
I'll show it more later but that's what
its intention is all right so if you
move forward or backwards we get the
camera Direction and we apply a force in
that direction that you're moving for
moving left or right
we also apply a force to the left to
right and as you can see these
directions go off the cameras get front
get right so that's how we're getting
them calculated add force with an
Impulse
um try to make it powerful enough to
seem legit that seemed to be about the
right calculation once we get Delta time
in here things might change again but
that's it we set move Force to true on
both of these so then if the move was
forced on this Frame we go ahead and
accumulate up this anti-glide timer
and then as long as it's been at least
one second of this anti-glide timer we
we do a push down and now this push down
basically stops slow gliding and it also
actually makes you properly fall off
cliffs so this actually might be a
little long because you could in theory
if you timed it just right run off a
cliff for a full second so maybe this
would be better as I got 0.5 every half
a second maybe we do it four times a
frame which is an awful lot I guess but
you know we never just have to test and
see what happens if wind move forced we
do a push down every you know it still
feels fine but I'm willing to bet that
if I fell off a cliff now or walked off
a physics something there's nothing to
walk off of here really but it should
push me down a little quicker and
um it makes it really hard to walk over
things because I'm constantly being
shoved down into them also it does nice
things like like I can totally ramp this
like I can just go boom and ramp super
high there's no getting over these walls
this uh collider for these walls goes up
and down indefinitely so there's no
getting out of this Square so when you
set up a level you definitely can't run
off the world that's just like that by
default we should probably just put in
the actual number I don't know it's
about it's about a 0.6 let's go with
that it's close enough
it's about every four frames and so
every time it pushes you down it resets
the timer so basically just accumulates
up presets the timer pushes you down now
there's another thing here there's a
player jumped Airborne setting we want
to see if the player jumped we'll mess
with that more later but if the player
did not jump and they're not moving in
any direction we want to set their speed
to zero so if the move was forced
but they're not moving uh we're gonna
stop them in place basically so
basically if you're not jumping and you
stop moving you should get locked in
place but also you might get a quick
push down before getting locked in place
I'm not sure if this is logically the
best here but it seems to work and this
is what creates that stop effect I think
I might want this in the anti-glide
timer actually
like just as a whole nother if
before the reset
yeah I think I want this like this that
way we don't do this every time a move
is forced but specifically only when a
move is forced and
they're no longer moved because this
first part should trigger even if you're
running this part should only trigger if
you've stopped moving but you still
might want this push down effect I don't
know
there's a lot of stuff to play around
with like that but we can give this a
quick run with that modified into this
anti-glide timer
um I think that'll work fine this should
actually this should help with the whole
ramping effect because we don't want to
ramp and Float forever
like you can kind of do all these you're
just basically ramming a capsule into
some little squares and it pops into the
air the anti-glide thing seems to be
pretty solid now overall so I think it's
kind of good enough for now good enough
so there that's fine we'll move on next
up still the same function we've got
some jump stuff and it's definitely a
hack first of all if you jump we're
going to reset the timer we're going to
push you up into the air pretty hard
Mass scale times 20 times the one it's
gonna be pretty hard to push up but it
won't feel like that much even though it
is all right and then if the player is
Airborne when you're going through this
and this could happen multiple times
because uh this only triggers once and
that's you know when they press jump and
they're not in the air this is going to
trigger as long as they're in the air so
this could continue to trigger
um we're going to declare a time and air
static variable so this is basically for
an accumulator and accumulate it based
on the jump timer.tick so how much time
has passed since this reset up here push
down once we don't want it to keep
shoving you down after a jump so we want
each push down to just be once and as
long as the time in air is greater than
the jump cooldown then it should shove
you down so it's about 0.5 seconds
you'll go upward for about half a second
and then you'll be shoved down pretty
hard that tends to be
how it goes here with the jumps okay so
if you don't do this push down thing
suddenly you get this very floaty
Parabola type jump so that's why I ended
up doing this push down effect rather
than letting gravity take its course
gravity will take its course but if you
happen to like stop in the air it like
you sit in the air and just float there
which I couldn't figure out what life
made maybe something to do with a
restitution but even adjusting it I
couldn't use it to feel right so I ended
up going with this push down effect so
here I'm going to jump a little jump and
then you can see the push down after
about half second half and it just feels
very floaty without that shutdown and
even with the shove down it feels pretty
floaty but if the static jump seems
somewhat okay now I could just say look
we're not jumping high enough let's just
boost this into Oblivion all right 80x
let's see how high we jump we'll still
get shoved down after five seconds but
here we go boom and now we're still
going up the shove down was not hard
enough to counteract and now you can see
we're just floating in the air not
moving now that's what I want to avoid
so we need to make this shove down
harder than the shove up so maybe we got
100 Exit here otherwise it's just going
to kind of slow us so this jump there's
no way this is the best way to do it
this is just what I figured out so hard
jump shut down that's not too bad right
there still feels a little floaty but at
least we can get a Run and Jump going on
unlike before
so maybe I'll leave those numbers there
for now it just seems a bit excessive
like we're adding an awful lot of force
to do a little thing all right that's
kind of janky but it's all heck then
time and error reset that back to zero
on this
so this is kind of like we've considered
being landed but it's it's a hack and
then we reset all the movement keys this
is just all the uh buttons you were
pressing it resets those but if you're
holding it down they're going to set
back the true before the next reset of
this anyway so if you're holding them
down they're still going to be true for
the next iteration of this last things
we do just update a few positions we
update our camera position uh to our
rigid body position but we can plus up a
little bit on the Y to make it look like
the camera is near where your head would
be so this just sets the position of the
camera to where we now are
and this shift pitching yard just sets
if you move your mouse basically the
player entity has a world pause that is
not the character pause it's just its
own world pause so we want to update
that too uh don't actually use this yet
but the game will eventually use these
so that's why I'm going ahead and
putting it in there for now so that's
the whole apply movement system the
whole first person movement system with
Nvidia physics
and that's where my buggy janky code is
right now and it's kind of good enough
as you saw but I hope you enjoyed this
video special thanks to my patrons for
uh
helping me make it
if you want to support this kind of
stuff you know there's a like button and
all that I don't want to get into all
that but I do want to say that very
specifically I am continuing this nice
making videos Trend thanks to my
supporters on patreon
[Music]
foreign